إذا حكمنا من خلال عظمة
هذا الجدار وطوله ، فقد يغفر لك
التفكير في أنه موجود في الصين ، لكن هذا هو
سور الهند العظيم ، أصبح
جدار الجرس يقع في ميراج أستانا على بعد
حوالي 10 ساعات بالسيارة من نيودلهي ،
وقد تسبب بعده في حدوث هذا المذهل
الموقع غير معروف نسبيًا حتى
بالنسبة إلى السكان المحليين ، يتكون الجدار من
آلاف الطوب الحجري مع ازدهار فني
في الأعلى ، وله سبع بوابات واستغرق
بناءه أكثر من قرن من الزمان ، وكان
مكانًا للجوء في أوقات الخطر ، حيث
يتصاعد الجدار عبر الوديان وعلى طول
قمم الجبال بعد سور
الصين العظيم هو ثاني أطول
جدار مستمر في العالم يبلغ طوله 22
ميلاً ويحيط
بحصن أكثر من 300 معبد قديم
يُعتقد أنه تم بناؤه في القرن الخامس
عشر في عام 2013 ، وقد تم إعلانه من قبل اليونسكو.
موقع تراث عالمي ، تقع غالبية
السور في مكان مرتفع
كمراقبة وإطلالات رائعة على
الجبال والأراضي الزراعية المحيطة
على عكس أي مكان آخر في  الهند